F: Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec Anne Cordin
A: Coucou *rire*
F: Vous la voyez d'ici aussi
Tu as vu tu es cernée par les caméras
A: Faut que je choisisse mon beau profil, je suis pas en contre plongée
F: C'est le succès, tu as vu tu es...
A: Ouais
F: Ah oui en contre plongée, c'est vrai je peux le remonter un peu. Regarde
A: Non mais c'est bon.
*rires*
F: Anne Cordin c'est une comédienne, une humoriste, une plein de choses
Je peux dire ça comme ça ou pas?
A: C'est ça, ouais ouais ouais
F: Anne elle a eu la chance de partir, enfin la chance tu as créé la chance
A: Exactement, faut pas dire qu'on a la chance... oui oui j'ai créé mon opportunité de partir
F: Donc elle a décidé de partir en Australie. Tu es partie combien de temps?
A: Je suis partie 9 mois exactement.
F: 9 mois
A: Un bébé
F: Le temps d'un bébé ouais
A: Voilà
F: Et tu es revenue enceinte d'ailleurs
A: Et oui enceinte de pleins de choses voilà
F: Enceinte de pleins de souvenirs
A: De pleins de souvenirs
F: J'ai des transitions de ouf, tu vas vite comprendre pourquoi !
J'aimerai s'il te plait Anne que tu prennes un de tes souvenirs
atypique, un truc marquant, un truc rigolo qui t'es arrivée en Australie et que je ne peux pas connaitre
A: D'accord
F: Sans me dire lequel
A: Ah oui, que tu puisses pas connaître, d'accord
F: Voilà
A: Pu*** j'en ai pleins
*rires*
a: C'est hyper dur. Bon vas y. Ok
F: C'est bon, tu t'es fixée sur un souvenir
A: Ouiais
F: Particulier
A: Ouais
F: Ok c'est parfait. Je ne peux pas le connaitre?
A: Je vais en prendre un autre alors, parce que du coup celui là tu pourrais le connaitre
F: Ou alors. ah c'est parce que tu en as peut être parlé sur Facebook ou un truc comme ça?
A: Oui voilà
F: Ben écoute sur tout ce que tu as raconté sur 9 mois
A: Ok, oui j'ai un autre souvenir ok
A: Ok, ouais encore plus atypique
F: C'est vrai
A: Ouais ouais
F: Ah ben du coup j'y gagne alors
A: Ouais
F: Je ne peux pas connaître cette anecdote?
F: C'est sûr et certains à 100%
A: Ouais
F: Ok, euh... je vais noter, moi des... choses que j'imagine que tu pourrais potentiellement raconter dans cette anecdote
Par exemple, euh... je te dis une grosse bêtise mais si je pense que tu vas me raconter une soirée, je peux marquer bière, fête ou des choses comme ça
je vais essayer de... pressentir en fait, de prédire un petit peu le style d'anecdote que tu vas me raconter
A: D'accord
F: et après on comparera à la fin
Ça marche?
A: Ouais ouais
F: Comme ça, ils vont voir ce que je vais marquer à l'avance. Tu vois pas ce que j'écris moi?
A: Non
F: Alors je vais essayer de noter des mots comme ça, pour prédire un peu ça
F: Je pense que tu vas parler d'un truc... un truc comme ça donc je vais l'écrire ici
Je sais pas je me demande si tu vas pas me parler de quelque chose comme ça
Alors j'ai quasiment un flash pour le dernier, je vais le marquer mais je ne vais pas leur faire voir. Même eux je veux qu'ils soit surpris si c'est bon
Je t'ai là.... je t'ai là
et je t'écoute, j'ai hâte de connaitre cette histoire
A: Ah du coup je raconte l'histoire
F: Oui oui tu me raconte comme ci j'étais un pote
fait semblant, fait semblant de bien m'aimer *rires*
A: Salut, tu sais pas si qui m'est arrivée en Australie, non mais truc de ouf
F: Ben non, racontes moi
A: Non mais un truc que tu peux pas faire en France, peut être, mais en fait je me suis occupée pendant 15jours de dauphins sauvages
F: De dauphins
A: Ouais
F: Je savais que t'avais élevé un bébé kangourou
A: Aussi, non mais ouais truc de ouf
F: Mais tu t'es occupée de dauphins sauvages
A: Aussi ouais ouais
F: Comment ça se fait?
A: Ben euh... le hasard. Ben oui le hasard *rires*
Je marchais puis euh... *rires*
Non, je voulais remonter vers... Je voulais faire un road trip sur la côte ouest
F: Ouais
A: Australienne
et donc je savais qu' à Monkey Mia, c'est le nom d'une plage, il y avais des dauphins
et donc je voulais y aller
et en tapant sur internet, je me suis rendue qu'on pouvait être volontaire
pour travailler avec les rangers
et du coup j'ai postulé, j'ai dit que je voulais travailler
F: D'accord
A: Du coup, ils m'ont pris tout de suite
F: C'est ouf
A: C'est pas payé mais au moins on s'occupe de dauphins. ils viennent tous les matins, on leur donne...
F: Quand tu dis "on est pas payé" ça s’appelle du?
A: Volontariat
F: ou du?
Bénévolat un petit peu
A: Bénévolat, ah ouais c'est ça
F: Bon peut être que... peut être que tu te doutes d'un des mots que j'ai écris maintenant *rires*
F: Ok, d'accord
*rires*
A: Ok
et puis... et donc... non après c'est... en gros c'est ça.
C'est que c'est atypique. Du coup, j'avais un dauphin , parce qu'il y a une trentaine de dauphins qui viennent
tous les matins, même toute la journée sur cette plage
F: Ouais
A: J'avais, il avait un dauphin que j'aimais tout particulièrement
et j'avais l'impression qu'il me reconnaissait
et je dis son prénom?
Il s'appelait... je dis son nom
F: Oui oui donne le
A: Il s'appelait Picolo
F: Picolo
A:  Voilà Picolo
F: Picolo comme dans...
A: Je sais pas
F: Dragon Ball
A: Ah je sais pas, ah ouais
F: Et si, il y a un picolo
A: Picolo et picolo en français ça fait...
F Ah ben oui
F: C'est pour ça qu'il te reconnaissait d'ailleurs
A: Oui voilà c'est pour ça. Moi je suis de Bourgogne
F: Et quand tu venais il te reconnaissait vraiment?
A: Ben je sais pas en fait j'avais l'impression que... qui... il me faisait parfois des bisous à la jambe, des petits câlins et tout
F: Et il le faisait pas forcément aux autres?
A: Ben euh... Moi en tout cas je me disais qu'il le faisait qu'à moi
F: Il le fait qu'à moi ok
A: Voilà mon petit Picolo je l'aimais bien
F: D'accord et donc...
A: D'ailleurs, c'est ma petite Picolo parce que c'était une femelle
F: Ah c'était une femelle
A: Ouais en fait on s'occuper que des femelles
les mâles euh... rien à foutre voilà *rires*
F: C'est chouette en tout cas de... toi avoir eu la démarche de t'inscrire comme ça
A: Oui et je pensais vraiment pas, en fait en Australie j'ai fait que des trucs que je ne pensais vraiment pas... que j'avais pas prévu de faire en partant
F: Pu***  c'est ouf
F: En fait, tu as fait on peut dire du Bénévolat
A: Oui
F: plus que du volontariat *rires*
A: enfin c'est la même chose
F: Oui c'est la même chose
F: Euh... Avec des dauphins dont un qui te reconnaissait du coup et qui s'appelait Picolo
A: Ouais
A: Voilà
F: Les gens, ils ont déjà vu que j'ai écris bénévolat,
A: D'accord
F: Les internautes ont vu que j'avais déjà écris dauphins
A: Ah bon.
F: Et Oui, j'ai écris une 3ème truc en fait, est ce que tu peux me dire le nom d'un des rangers par exemple?
A: Euh... je m'en rappelle plus, non
F: Ah tu te rappelle plus, en fait le seul nom de cette histoire c'est le nom du dauphin Picolo?
A: Ouais
F: Ouais !
F: Et bien moi sur le bloc note j'avais écris Picolo
A: NOOOON
F: Et si, j'avais juste écrit ça
Picolo
F: Mais si. *rires*
F: C'est quoi ton actu en ce moment? Qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur toi?
A: Ah ben je joue en duo avec ma sœur... jumelles Sophie
on s'appelle Les Demoiselles et on joue là le 9 mars à Bordeaux
dans le cadre du festival Les culottés de l'humour
Et, grande nouvelle, en exclusivité je peux vous annoncer qu'on va jouer au festival d'Avignon
F: Ah c'est cool
A: Ouaiiiiis
F: Ben ouais c'est cool grave
F: Donc si vous avez pas bien compris Anne, elle a une sœur jumelle qui s'appelle Sophie
et du coup, elles font un duo
Elles font un duo mais comme elles sont qu'une à la fois sur scène tu as l'impression que c'est un One
F: Non je déconne
A: Non mais c'est ça, c'est un solo en fait
F: Ah c'est drôle
A: Un solo jouait en duo, non mais c'est exactement ça
F: C'est tellement drôle
A: Tu es trop fort
F: Ben écoute j'avais aussi noté dans le carnet, tu sais le mec qui n'arrête jamais
Et quand à nous rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!
F J'ai l'impression que ça t'énerve?
A: Ah ouais c'est chiant *rire* alalala